[Music]
politics has constantly been changing
it's exhilarating it can be exasperating
the truth is that carl and i don't see
eye to eye on some things we'll just
keep this between us but i actually like
the guy
there goes my career reagan used to say
that our american democracy was always
one generation away from extinction
we're more polarized now than ever
that's understandable we're in a tribal
moment
in a great campaign you have a very
clear sense of what
it's about a lot of the campaign is
going to depend upon the message
donald trump was the anti-obama he held
himself
out as i'm going to take a brick and
throw it through the blade glass window
mission accomplished if you're in a
campaign and you don't believe you're
going to make a mistake you're in the
wrong business
the less it is when you're attacked
respond impeach the charge
and then go back on the offensive i have
as much experience as jack kennedy did
senator you're no jack kennedy how right
there
these are battles of definition each
candidate is trying to say
i'm the answer to your question in this
election exactly
it's a performance and look at the
campaigns in the 19th century
and they were brutal they just weren't
on television
the one corrective in a democracy is the
vote
our moment is now
[Applause]
if you've never been involved in
politics don't be afraid to get started
it is really important to be
agents of change politics is a wonderful
noble
profession and it ought to be the
passion of every single american
if you want change this is your choice
[Music]
no well said i'm david axelrod
i'm karl rove and this is our master
class
you